hello i'm lieutenant david valenta views
and victor a-l-e-n-t-a
with the lvmpd homicide sex crimes
bureau
we're out here today on a dead body call
we're treating as a suspicious death
investigation
at approximately 7 a.m this morning
metro dispatch received a call of a dead
body found in the desert area
immediately north of alta and
crossbridge that is in the far west end
of town
it appears some construction workers
were coming in to work at a job site at
which time they located that a dead body
and notified police
police and detectives in crime scene are
currently on scene we do have a deceased
male who has yet to be identified who is
down in the desert with apparent trauma
to their head
uh we have no specific uh cause of death
at this time we're still waiting the
coroner's office to further the
investigation
as stated this is currently just deemed
a suspicious death investigation
we have no specific suspect information
at this time
as usual we
are requesting anyone with any
information
to reach out call metro police you can
stay anonymous calling crime stoppers or
email homicide lvmpd.com
with that take a couple of
state of the questions or how long it
might have been out there
uh we're still waiting on corner to
arrive that'll further some of that
investigative things we don't believe it
had been out here
extremely long
based on preliminary investigation
i'm not going to give that out at this
time yet the person hasn't been
identified uh there's a few things we're
not ready to release yet
is the construction area like are people
going there every day or is it not
popular
it's not a very busy area it looks like
where just some equipment is uh housed
so it's not right in the middle of
actual construction site
uh it's a popular hiking area
as well as where some construction
equipment is kept
thank you very much